Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui on va parler de notre espèce: Homo Sapiens
Je suis sûr qu'on vous a déjà raconté l'histoire de l'évolution de l'homme en utilisant cette image.
Vous savez… un truc du genre «L'Australopithèque…
…qui s'est transformé en Homo Erectus…
…qui a donné l'Homme de Néandertal, qui a finalement évolué en Homo Sapiens.»
Bon, et bien aujourd'hui on va voir pourquoi
ça ne s'est vraiment pas passé comme ça!
Cette image qui est sensée représenter l'évolution des espèces humaines,
on la trouve partout. Je me souviens…
elle était dans ma salle de classe quand j'étais au collège.
Et si vous, aujourd'hui, vous vous amusez à taper «Évolution» dans Google Image,
vous allez voir que c'est ça qui sort partout.
Le problème de cette image…
c'est qu'elle donne une vision complètement erronée de ce qu'est l'évolution.
Quand on regarde cette image, on a l'impression que l'évolution se fait en ligne…
vous savez, une espèce qui en donne une autre… qui en donne une autre…
En fait, l'évolution, ça ne marche pas comme ça: l'évolution, ça marche en arbre.
C'est un peu comme un arbre généalogique.
C'est à dire que si on part d'une espèce à un moment donné… peut être…
qu'elle va finalement évoluer en deux sous-espèces différentes qui elles mêmes
vont donner plusieurs espèces… et ainsi de suite.
Et comme dans un arbre généalogique,
il peut y avoir des branches qui prospèrent… et puis d'autres qui s'éteignent
Et bien, pour l'évolution des différentes espèces humaines, ça s'est passé pareil,
ça ne s'est pas passé en ligne droite, ças'estpasséenarbre.
Le problème, c'est que l'arbre d'évolution des espèces humaines, on ne le connaît pas
La seule chose qu'on ait, c'est des fossiles
qu'on a trouvé un petit peu partout, qui ne sont pas forcément tous complets.
Et, à partir des fossiles,
en les comparant les uns avec les autres,
on essaye de reconstituer l'arbre de l'évolution humaine.
Alors ça, c'est très compliqué parce qu'il y a certainement des tas d'espèces…
dont on n'a jamais trouvé de fossile.
Donc si ça se trouve, il y a des pans entiers de l'arbre qu'on a raté complètement!
L'autre difficulté c'est qu'au fur et à mesure des temps…
l'homme s'est amusé à migrer sur la planète.
Et donc on peut très bien avoir à un moment donné,
une espèce humaine qui prospère sur un continent pendant qu'elle s'éteint sur un autre.
Ce que je voudrais vous montrer aujourd'hui, c'est ce qu'on connaît à peu près
de l'évolution et des différentes migrations des espèces humaines.
Alors vous allez voir que c'est très approximatif, mais
ça reste quand même mieux que cette image de l'évolution en ligne.
La première espèce que l'on a classé danslegenreHomo,
elle est apparue il y a environ deux millions d'années
à l'est de l'Afrique.
C'est celle qu'on appelle Homo Habilis.
Alors, Homo Habilis… probablement, il descend d'une espèce d'australopithèque…
mais on ne sait pas forcément laquelle.
Ce qui distingue Homo Habilis de ses prédécesseurs,
c'est déjà son volume crânien qui était plus important,
et surtout que c'est probablement la première espèce humaine qui a commencé à se servir d'outils.
Un peu plus tard, il y a un million et demi d'années,
est apparue une autre espèce remarquable,
c'est Homo Erectus.
Homo Erectus, ce qui fait sa particularité,
c'est que ça a été la première espèce humaine àsortird'Afrique.
Homo Erectus a quitté l'Afrique et est parti vers l'Asie
et s'est développé en Asie.
Un peu plus tard, il y a environ cinq-cent-mille ans,
est apparue une autre espèce humaine,
qu'on a appelée Homo Heidelbergensis.
C'est une espèce qui a aussi migré hors d'Afrique, mais plutôt en direction de l'Europe centrale.
Et donc, c'est encore bien plus tard, il y a seulementdeux-cent-mille ans,
qu'est enfin apparue notre espèce, Homo Sapiens.
Alors… Homo Sapiens est lui aussi apparu dans un petit coin de l'Afrique de l'Est
et, pendant un bon moment, il est resté en Afrique.
Et c'est seulement il y a cinquante-mille ans
qu'il est sorti et qu'il s'est répandu sur lesdifférentscontinents.
Il faut bien se rendre compte que cinquante-mille ans, à l'échelle de l'évolution,
c'est vraiment rien du tout! La vie existe depuis trois milliards d'années,
la lignée humaine s'est séparée de celle du chimpanzé depuis sept millions d'années
donc cinquante-mille ans, c'était vraiment hier.
Et ce qu'il faut bien réaliser, c'est qu'au moment ou Homo Sapiens décide de sortir d'Afrique,
il n'est pas du tout le premier à faire ça!
c'est à dire qu'il y a déjà d'autres espèces humaines,
qu'on a vues, qui étaient déjà sorties d'Afrique
Et donc, fatalement, quand Homo Sapiens commence à se pointer sur les différents continents,
il tombe sur les descendants de ceux qui étaient sortisbeaucoup plus tôt.
On pense aujourd'hui qu'à l'époque où Homo Sapiens a colonisé les différents continents,
il existait au minimum trois autres espèces humaines.
La première, c'est la plus connue, c'est
l'Homme de Néandertal
On a longtemps pensé que l'Homme de Néandertal
était une sorte de… soit d'ancêtre, soit de proche cousin d'Homo Sapiens.
Ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui c'est qu'en fait l'Homme de Néandertal
est plutôt un cousin lointain d'Homo Sapiens.
Vous voyez, c'est un descendant de Heidelbergensis,
qui était sorti d'Afrique il y a cinq-cent-mille ans.
L'autre espèce que Sapiens a croisé quand il a commencé à se balader, c'est
un cousin de Néandertal qu'on appelle l'HommedeDenisova.
C'est une espèce qu'on n'a découvert que très récemment
et qui aussi un descendant de Heidelbergensis,
mais qui avait migré plutôt vers l'Asie centrale.
Et enfin, il y a une troisième espèce dont on n'est pas sûr que Sapiens l'ait vraiment croisée physiquement,
mais dont on est sûr qu'elle vivait déjà en Asie du sud-est àla même époque.
C'est ce qu'on appelle l'Homme de Florès.
L'Homme de Florès, c'était une tout petite espèce, il faisait à peu près un mètre,
et parfois on l'a appelé le Hobbit, d'ailleurs,
et c'était certainement un lointain descendant de HomoErectus.
Donc vous voyez que là, c'était vraiment un cousin
très éloigné de Homo Sapiens
puisque Homo Erectus était sorti d'Afrique il y a plus d'un million d'années.
Donc si, finalement, on essaie de reconstituer
l'arbre de l'évolution humaine à partir de ce qu'on vientdevoir,
on trouve plutôt un truc dans ce genre là.
Avec H. Habilis, H. Erectus, H. Heidelbergensis,
et puis quatre espèces qui ont probablement vécu
au même moment sur les différents continents.
Vous voyez que c'est quand même quelque chose de
très différent de l'évolution en ligne, où l'on a des espèces qui se suivent à la queue leu leu.
Bon alors, la suite de l'histoire, je pense que vous la connaissez…
parmi toutes ces espèces humaines, qui vivaient
sur les différents continents il y a quelques dizaines de milliers d'années,
Et bien, aujourd'hui, il n'en reste plus qu'une, c'est nous!
Alors, il y a différentes hypothèses sur la manière dontça s'est passé
On a envie de penser que Homo Sapiens a
vaincu physiquement les autres espèces.
En fait, il se peut très bien, simplement, queHomoSapiens
était mieux adapté que les autres,
et, peut-être sous l'effet de changements climatiques,
les autres espèces se sont éteintes et HomoSapiensestresté.
Alors… tout ça aurait pu en rester là, mais
il faut savoir qu'il y a quelques années,
il y a eu une vraie petite révolution qui a été apportée par une équipe de recherche allemande.
En fait, ces gens là ont réussi pour la première fois
à analyser de l'ADN de fossile.
Il faut bien voir ce que cela a d'exceptionnel,
d'habitude quand on fait une analyse ADN, on prélève du sang ou de la salive,
à la limite dans les scènes de crime, on peut faire une analyse ADN sur un cheveu, mais bon…
ça reste quelque chose qui n'est pas très vieux.
Là, ils ont réussi à faire une analyse ADN
de fossiles qui avaient plusieurs dizaines de milliersd'années.
Et donc, ils ont notamment analysé…
le génome de Néandertal.
Et en faisant cela, ils ont découvert que
notre génome, à nous Homo Sapiens,
contenait environ 4% de gènes
qui venaient de l'Homme de Néandertal.
Ce pourcentage là, en fait, il varie suivant les populations,
il est plus élevé chez les européens et les asiatiques
et il est moins élevé chez les africains.
Et ce que cela suggère, c'est qu'en fait,
il y ait eu, au moment où Sapiens est sorti d'Afrique,
ce que les scientifiques appellent un flux de gènes
entre Sapiens et Néandertal.
Alors «flux de gènes» qu'est ce que ça veut dire? Çaveut dire qu'ils ont couché ensemble.
Et… encore plus fort,
la même équipe a analysé aussi
l'ADN de Denisova, qui était une autre espèce quivivaitàl'époque
et ils ont vu que, là aussi,
il y avait aussi un peu du génome de Denisova dans Homo Sapiens,
mais seulement pour certaines populations,
qui sont les mélanésiens qui vivent en Asie du sud-est, par exemple en Papouasie-Nouvelle-Guinée.
Donc ce qu'on pense, c'est que
Sapiens et Denisova ont aussi fricoté ensemble
et probablement au moment
d'une migration de Sapiens vers l'Asie du Sud-est.
Quand même, ne vous faites pas trop d'illusions sur la manière dont ça s'est passé.
On a envie de s'imaginer un truc romantique,
au coin du feu, au fond de la caverne,
Monsieur Néandertal qui fait la cour à Madame Sapiens
Bon… de toutes façons, quelque soit la manière dont
ça s'est passé, maintenant vous savez que
notre espèce Homo Sapiens
est quand même beaucoup plus complexe
que ce qu'on pouvait s'imaginer avant!
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo, n'hésitez pas à la partager si elle vous a plu.
Sachez que vous pouvez vous abonner à la chaine «Science étonnante»,
vous pouvez aussi me retrouver sur mon blog qui s'appelle aussi «Science étonnante»
…et vous pouvez me suivre sur Facebook ou sur Twitter.
Merci et à bientôt!